hallo mein name ist luca und herzlich
willkommen zu einer weiteren folge
anteil an turnt war ja dieses zombie
survival spiel wo ich euch die erste
folge x hier verlinkt da habe ich jetzt
auch zeitgleich habe ich die zweite
folge drin verlinkt oder so ich bin hier
gerade einfach mal auf einem server
gespenst von kommunisten auto direkt am
anfang wir uns hat keiner akku ich bin
jetzt einfach mal offenen server
gegangen der irgendwie washington versus
the mini oder so heiß das problem ist
nur gerade das gerade nacht ich weiß
nicht ob es daran liegt dass ist auch
gerade zwei und acht ist wo ich das
ganze video aufnehmen weil ich so viel
vor produzieren muss aber ich habe
überhaupt keine ahnung ich weiß auch
nicht ob ich jetzt schon ist das ein
mein gott es ist ein format ist ein
kombi freunde ich glaube ich disconnect
immer lieber von dem server nicht weil
ich angst habe vor diesen beiden zombies
da sondern weil es einfach viel zu
dunkel ist gibt's halt so viele spieler
auf so vielen verschiedenen maps sich
nehmen jetzt einfach mal die nie
auf dieser map ihr zumindest schon mal
tag das ist ganz gut dann können wir
mich jetzt ein bisschen unser unwesen
treiben ist eigentlich jedem app anders
kann man das selbst unser inventar ist
bei jay wieder komplett auf null weil
wir ja wie gesagt gerade im online modus
sind das heißt ich muss jetzt wieder
hier die zombies angreifen überhaupt
welches ich sollte diesmal echt
vorsichtiger sein alter die wissen alles
viel stärker auf einmal als im
singleplayer ich hab einen zombie
verprügelt und noch 28 11 was mache ich
denn ich schleiche mich einfach mal hier
durch das dickicht so ein bisschen an
ihrem sind oder ausgangs drin da hinten
sind zwei zombie stars ein zombie und
davon um die ecke ist auch noch mal ein
zombie es ist ein bisschen viel gerade
hier heritage valley in einer minute
hier vorne kann ich auch nicht rein weil
da wieder ein zombie ist alter das ist
alles voll mit zombies ihr ich versuche
jetzt einfach mal den hier dort
rauszunehmen locken damit ich da
irgendwie hallo kann sein dass er mich
gar nicht sieht irgendwie doch er hat
mich doch gesehen ganz locker luca
einfach ein bisschen zurück laufen und
haben immer so ein bisschen schlage
genauso wieder und so wieder schlagen
und so wieder schlagen und so wieder
schlagen 15 leben oh mein gott 0% leben
wie konnte ich grad 0% leben noch leben
das ist auf diesem verdammten servern
einfach viel schwieriger als im single
player wie sollte ich denn hier
überleben allerdings haben wir diesen
familie hätten ja schon mal aus diesem
haus daraus gelotst das heißt
theoretisch könnte ich da mal eben
reinlaufen ist hier jemand hallo ich
möchte eigentlich nur kurz hier hoch und
mich mal umschauen ob ich hier
vielleicht hier ist halt einfach gar
nichts wir haben hier auf jeden fall 35
prozent
ich hasse den server jetzt schon wow wir
sehen wieder unfassbar tolle aus da
unten ist ein zombie
ich hab mir den knochen gebrochen ich
wollte eigentlich gar nicht runter
springen
so ist es dem eba für eine scheiße ist
tatsächlich so dass es immer eine
unterschiedliche web ist das hier ist
jetzt nämlich gerade die map auf der ich
mich gerade befinde
da ist der kartbahn der zwischenstand
ist 21 prozent gesundheit 2 100 sprinten
aber ich kann nicht sprinten weil ich
meine knochen gebrochen habe
das heißt wenn mich jetzt ein zombie
erwischt bin ich tot
gute voraussetzungen ich bin ja und
ehrlich mit euch und zwar nachdem ich
part 1 am 16 dezember hochgeladen habe
und part 2 und einen zwanzigster
dezember hochgeladen habe und jetzt
bereits am 29 dezember hochladen
zu dem zeitpunkt der aufnahme hier ist
gerade der 14 12 in der nacht deswegen
konnte ich mir noch keine tipps tricks
schild schied et cetera von euch durch
leben tut mir leid ich bin am
vorproduzieren mein tag besteht derzeit
ca daraus dass ich sechs stunden beim
praktikum bin und danach dann quarkmasse
raceway bin quasi sechs stunden beim
praktikum danach mache ich noch youtube
danach noch lernen und danach noch in
die andere sachen machen wie keine
ahnung putzen einkaufen whatever dann
ging noch fünf stunden schlaf
zusammenkratzen weiter hinten den unfall
deswegen bin ich halt derzeit zu gast am
vorproduziert und weichheit über
weihnachten immer vom skiurlaub wenn
aber kuba wieder gefunden und ich kann
wieder sprinten ich weiß nicht was ich
auf diesem raceway jetzt machen soll
aber er sieht cool aus tatsächlich ich
habe hier gerade irgendwas gefunden ich
weiß allerdings nicht was das ist ich
kann das starten und stoppen
leicht ist das ein benzintank es wenn
ich mit einem auto an komme ich das hier
auffüllen kann
ich habe ehrlich gesagt überhaupt keine
ahnung was nicht soll deswegen verpisst
ich mich immer einfach wieder weil ich
endlich mal ein paar items benötige
freund kann ich machen dann zeige ich
irgendwohin und ich kann machen dann
winke ich das ganze wird allerdings
wirklich viel mehr sinn machen wenn hier
noch andere spieler wären ich weiß dass
die grafik von dem spiel ultra simpel
ist und ich weiß auch dass hier gerade
keine spieler irgendwie auf dem server
sind und ich auch gerade irgendwie keine
zombies und keine items sehe aber es
macht mir tatsächlich trotzdem spaß ich
habe jetzt ganz einfach mal ein server
geträumt wo 22 spieler drauf sind er
schneidet hier gerade tatsächlich und
irgendwo hier müssten auch ein paar
spieler seien mit denen ich mich wohl in
g diese verlegten schaden schaut mir
freunde da hinten sind andere spieler
mache ich das richtig hey freunde was
geht ich bin ich mag euch ich mag dich
sowieso mein vater gestorben ein zombie
ihr seid
ich dachte ich habe jetzt einen tollen
kommen kumpel kennengelernt und ist er
so schlecht wie ich aber ich würde sagen
freunde das was mit diesem land hören da
ich wirklich noch keins der videos und
kommentare gelesen habe zu den ersten
beiden spielen jetzt auch nicht zu
diesem video
schreibt eure meinung in die kommentare
mir macht das spiel ultra viel spaß vor
allem im multiplayer vielleicht welches
man mit einem anderen youtuber zusammen
zocken oder einem kumpel oder so david
jeden fall noch mal auf dem server mit
anderen spielern und dann sehen wir uns
vielleicht im nächsten video wieder